[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue à tous ravi de vous
retrouver émission spéciale 49-3 ce soir
dans savouregard Il était 17h40 cet
après-midi quand la Première ministre
Elisabeth borne a déclenché le fameux
article de la Constitution dans
l'hémices sur le fondement de l'article
49 alinéa 3 de la Constitution
j'engage la responsabilité de mon
gouvernement pour la première partie du
projet de loi de finance pour 2023 voilà
le budget 2023 est donc adopté sans vote
sauf si une motion censure est évoquée
dans les prochains jours l'opposition
crie au déni de démocratie comment les
Français vont-ils interpréter ce passage
en force on va revenir dans le détail
sur les conséquences politiques de ce
premier 49.3 de la législature le
premier sans doute d'une longue série on
sera à l'Assemblée en direct des quatre
colonnes avec Stéphanie Despierres et
puis en plateau de nombreux invités
jusqu'à 20h30 des députés bien sûr mais
aussi des constitutionnalistes des
philosophes voilà pour le menu de CV
spécial 49-3 c'est parti
[Musique]
cette fois ça y est le couperet est
tombé après 7 jours laissés au débat
parlementaire la première ministre a
engagé la responsabilité de son
gouvernement sur la première partie du
projet de loi de finances pour 2023 cela
fait 30 ans
considéré cette date quand même avec un
49 tram n'avait pas été utilisé sur le
budget de l'État depuis
1992 et Pierre Bérégovoy bonsoir
François Cormier boligeon et merci
d'être là bienvenue sur ce plateau vous
êtes député Renaissance je le rappelle à
ceux qui ne suivent pas la politique au
jour le jour Renaissance et le parti
présidentiel député du Cher vous allez
débattre ce soir avec Raquel Garrido
député à les filles de Seine-Saint-Denis
qui va nous rejoindre dans quelques
petites minutes bonsoir Jean-Philippe
dorrosier bonsoir bienvenue sur ce
plateau constitutionnaliste professeur
de droits publics à l'Université de
Lille vous signez une tribune dans le
monde aujourd'hui sur le 49.3 activé au
bon moment écrivez-vous il n'affaiblit
pas notre démocratie vous nous direz
bien si c'était le un bon moment
aujourd'hui ou pas selon vous bonsoir
Pierre-Henri tavoyau ravi de vous
retrouver sur ce plateau philosophe vous
avez beaucoup écrit sur la démocratie
sur la pratique du pouvoir comment
gouverner un peuple roi chez Odile Jacob
reste un ouvrage de référence pour
comprendre la période politique dans
laquelle nous sommes vous êtes maître de
conférence à la Sorbonne et président du
collège de philosophie je vous donne la
parole dans quelques petites minutes
mais on va évidemment revoir ou voir
pour ceux qui ne l'ont pas vu le film de
la journée à l'Assemblée avec vous elles
à mon Agava bonsoir à vous bonsoir 49-3
motion de censure si j'aime bien compris
chacun joue sa partie
alors vous avez tous suivi minute par
minute il était elle a 17h35 quand
Elisabeth borne est arrivé au Palais
Bourbon oui évidemment la première
ministre elle était évidemment très
attendue elle est venue à pied à
l'Assemblée nationale son arrivée était
scrutée par tous les journalistes
présents mais aussi par les députés des
oppositions regardez sur le compte
Twitter de Mathilde panot c'est la
présidente de la groupe du groupe de la
France insoumise et bien la première
ministre arrive dans la cour d'honneur
une première ministre baptisée madame
49.3
17h39 elle traverse le couloir qui
l'amène dans le périmètre sacré et puis
elle pénètre enfin dans l'hémicycle
alors à ce moment-là Myriam il y a plus
aucun suspense parce que si la première
ministre est là il peut y avoir qu'une
seule raison c'est qu'elle va annoncer
le 49-3 un 49-3 dont elle fait porter la
responsabilité sur qui bien sûr les
oppositions
ensuite et surtout les oppositions pour
toute réaffirmer leur volonté de rejeter
le texte
en responsabilité nous devons donner un
budget à notre pays
alors évidemment et là attention je vais
me livrer à une analyse politique très
très fine bah la majorité dans
l'hémicycle qu'est-ce qu'ils font mais
ils sont d'accord alors ils
applaudissent tous en coeur la première
ministre les oppositions elles sont pas
d'accord évidemment donc on les voit il
applaudissent pas la nupestre elle
décide carrément et bien de quitter
l'hémicycle elle quitte l'hémicycle
avant même que la première ministre elle
est finie sa déclaration il faut dire
qu'ils avaient d'ores et déjà donné
rendez-vous quelques mètres plus loin
salle des quatre colonnes aux
journalistes les quatre présidents de
groupes de la nupes s'expriment tour à
tour les uns après les autres on les
écoute nous ne gouvernons pas la France
à coup de 49,3 et c'est pourquoi la nuit
Pesse qui se tient devant vous a décidé
sciences tenante de déposer une motion
de censure si ce n'est pas une surprise
jusqu'au fond les premiers à avoir parlé
de cette hypothèse
sont les ministres eux-mêmes c'est
évidemment une déception sur le plan du
débat parlementaire et du fonctionnement
de notre démocratie depuis huit jours
ils nous ont traités comme des
paillassons l'utilisation du 49-3 et un
aveu de faiblesse pour un gouvernement
qui ne sait pas travailler avec la
pluralité politique de l'Assemblée alors
la nuit pêche a pas attendu ils ont
couru déposés leurs motion de censure
pour qu'elles soient bien la première à
être déposée et validé par la Présidence
de l'Assemblée nationale il y aura une
autre motion de censure déposer
également voilà c'est pour ça qu'il y a
eu un peu une course de vitesse mais
c'était pas besoin de courir parce que
le rassemblement national eux ils vont
déposer une motion de censure mais alors
ils sont pas du tout du tout pressé
écoutez Jean-Philippe Tanguy nous allons
déposer une notion censure d'ici demain
on a 24 heures pour le faire voilà
Marine Le Pen et le groupe souhaite
peser les mots bien les choisir pour
qu'elle soit le plus consensuelle
possible la plus rassembleuse possible
car nous espérons toujours que d'autres
députés d'autres forces politiques
pourraient la soutenir même la signer
alors dans cette séquence qui s'ouvre
post 49,3 le calendrier est déterminant
quand est-ce que ces potions seront
déposées et débattus surtout et est-ce
qu'elles ont une chance d'être adopté
alors il faut attendre évidemment de
savoir quand est-ce que le rassemblement
national la dépose ils ont jusqu'à
demain 17h pour le faire après ça il y a
un délai de 48 heures où on ne peut pas
examiner l'émotion de censure et puis
elles peuvent être débattues dans les
trois jours ouvrés ce qui nous donne en
langage en français samedi ou lundi avec
une petite préférence peut-être pour
lundi alors il y a pas vraiment de
suspense non plus sur cette notion de
censure si vraiment il y a une chance
qu'une motion soit adoptée il faudrait
qu'elle soit signée par la droite et les
députés droites pour l'instant ils n'ont
pas du tout du tout l'intention de
signer une notion écouter le patron des
députés à l'air à l'Assemblée c'est
Olivier marlex
inutile de rajouter du chaos au cas où
ça t'assemblée nationale elle fonctionne
depuis 8 semaines si mes calculs sont
bons depuis la session extraordinaire et
donc très sincèrement ce ne serait pas
sérieux de rajouter du désordre au
désordre laissons cet assemblée
travaillait et que le gouvernement
écoute malgré tout malgré cette
procédure ce que les groupes
d'opposition lui ont exprimé tout au
long des débats
vous êtes tout raconté ça je vais pas le
jeter à la poubelle je le range dans mon
classeur parce qu'à mon avis il va se
passer à peu près la même chose des 49
ans on annoncent beaucoup peut-être sur
le budget de la Sécurité sociale ça peut
être d'ici la fin de semaine et à peu
près tout le monde devrait dire encore
camper à peu près sur ces positions vous
avez vu un jour sans fin vous souvenez
du film on va voir merci merci pour
cette présentation en images très
efficace François Cormier belligent vous
avez entendu des groupes d'opposition de
droits comme de gauche simulacre de
démocratie Parlement bafoué mépris coût
de force est-ce que pour un
parlementaire déjà quand on subit un
49-3 c'est pas quand même à tout le
moins un aveu de faiblesse d'abord je
pense que les Français qui nous
regardent et qui voient les oppositions
la nupesse parler comme elle le fait cet
après-midi il voit bien qu'il y a
beaucoup d'outrances et on sait que tout
ce qui est excessif est insignifiant il
y a une forme de comédien del arte avec
plutôt des mauvais acteurs pas très
convaincants mais c'est une épreuve
quand même vous éprouvez pour la
première fois dans l'hémic le fait que
vous n'êtes pas majoritaire c'est quand
même une épreuve ça non moi je suis très
attaché au parlementarisme à la
démocratie représentative et donc très
attachée à la souveraineté du peuple le
peuple français a choisi de reconduire
Emmanuel Macron à l'Élysée de lui
accorder à nouveau une majorité mais une
majorité qui est relative et donc nous
devons travailler avec cette majorité
relative nous sommes nous déterminés à
dialoguer avec l'ensemble des groupes
qui sont dans l'arc démocratique et
républicains nous avons préparé ce
budget avec l'ensemble des groupes qui
ont été invités à Bercy dans les
dialogues de Bercy la première ministre
Elisabeth borne a reçu l'ensemble des
présidents de groupe pour préparer ce
budget mais rien à se reprocher c'est ça
nos oppositions nous ont dit nous ne
voterons pas le budget alors il faut
bien en tirer des conclusions bonsoir
avec nous députés insoumise de Seine on
entendait les oppositions Mathilde panot
votre présidente de groupe en tête c'est
vrai que les mots sont très forts ce
soir Parlement bafoué coût de force on
n'est pas un peu dans un jeu de posture
dans la mesure où voilà c'est tout sauf
une surprise et après tout c'est un
outil dans la Constitution ce 49-3 c'est
un outil qui figure effectivement dans
la Constitution mais il n'est pas
interdit de formuler un avis citoyen sur
la portée des articles qui constituent
une constitution et Constitution il y en
a dans tous les pays et pour certains
très antidémocratiques et pourtant il y
a des constitutions et en France il y a
eu plusieurs textes différents dans
l'histoire de notre pays certains plus
parlementariste que d'autres certains
donnant moins de pouvoir au Parlement
certains donc on peut pour vous le
gouvernement n'a pas recherché le
compromis pourtant c'est sept jours de
débats laissés au débat sur le budget
mais justement c'est ça qui est frappant
c'est que
au départ vous avez pu voir que le
gouvernement comptait un peu sur la
thèse chez en lit
[Musique]
bien avoir lieu pendant une semaine et
je trouve ça très grave c'est dit on va
y revenir dans le détail mais on va
faire un tout petit peu d'histoire pour
terminer ce tour de table ce premier
tour de table j'enfile de rosier le 49-3
1958 c'est la Constitution qui
l'introduit la Cinquième République puis
ensuite il est limité en 2008 c'est ça
oui c'est ça en 1958 le 49-3 est
introduit avec une finalité très précise
qui participe de ce que l'on appelle la
rationalisation du parlementarisme
c'est-à-dire permettre à l'exécutif de
contrôler le gouvernement le Parlement
pardon dans le cadre de la procédure
législative ce qui n'était pas en mesure
de faire dans la République dans la
Constitution précédente entre 46 et 58
la finalité du 49.3 était disais très
précise c'est de créer une majorité sur
un texte lorsqu'elle n'existe pas ou
lorsqu'elle est incertaine et donc
permettre que un texte que souhaite à
tout prix l'exécutif soit néanmoins
adopté certes sans vote parce que
précisément vote la majorité n'existe
pas où elle est incertaine par exemple
lorsque Manuel Valls a eu recours à deux
reprises aux 49-3 sur la loi Macron et
sur la loi el khomri
parce que il y avait les il y avait les
frondeurs et aujourd'hui lorsque
Isabelle borne a recours à ce 49 francs
je pense qu'on aura l'occasion de
revenir sur l'instant qui n'est
peut-être pas le milieu le mieux choisi
mais en tout cas la majorité des
oppositions un coup funeste c'est très
grave voilà les mots de Raquel Garrido
est-ce que est-ce que pour vous le
moment choisi est opportun il y a eu
sept jours de débats laissés au débat
sur il y a aussi un temps programmé qui
fait que c'était ce soir minuit c'est le
règlement de l'Assemblée que la première
partie du projet de loi de finances
devait être bouclée est-ce que c'était
le bon moment selon vous non la
Constitution prévoit l'article 47 un
délai de 40 jours pour l'Assemblée
nationale seulement pour l'Assemblée
nationale pour adopter la loi de
finances en première lecture ce délai de
40 expire le 17 novembre on est le 19
octobre on a encore un petit peu de
marge donc je pense que l'instant est un
petit peu trop proche le levier est
activé peut-être un petit peu trop tôt
coupant en cours au débat parlementaire
juste vous m'avez interrogé sur
l'histoire j'ajoute un dernier point
Michel Rocard qui consiste souvent en
exemple de celui qui a le plus utilisé
le 49-3 c'est vrai parce qu'il était en
a même configuration qu'Elisabeth board
mais jamais il n'a interrompu un débat
budgétaire c'est-à-dire qu'il a utilisé
le 49-3 moment où le débat s'est
déterminé simplement pour sécuriser le
vote c'est-à-dire en utilisant le 49-3
pour ce pourquoi il était initialement
prévu donc j'entends quand même que il y
a une petite entaille à la démocratie
parlementaire via le moment du recours à
cette arme ou à cet outil
constitutionnel Pierre-Henri tavoyau la
démocratie est-elle affaiblie je vous ai
entendu sur un plateau récent expliquer
que vos étudiants considéraient que le
49-3 c'était la dictature
oui c'est assez surprenant c'est-à-dire
que le 49-3 fait partie de la
Constitution la Cinquième République par
ailleurs c'est pas effectivement un acte
autoritaire comme on le dit puisque il y
a un risque le risque c'est
effectivement qu'un gouvernement tombe
donc c'est pas un acte qu'on prend comme
ça sans risque ce qu'elle a
caractéristique la tyrannie ou la
dictature donc là il y a effectivement
un trouble qui est un peu alimenté par
les discours qui sont qui sont présentés
quelque chose je trouve un peu nocif
parce que
vous voyez à dire qu'on sort de la
démocratie qu'on rentre dans une logique
de dictature franchement c'est une
grosse différence c'est pas la pneumonie
que la démocratie moi je trouve que
c'est un peu périlleux parce que il y a
plusieurs qualités de démocratie et
aujourd'hui moi je considère que nous
vivons dans un régime très spécifique
que je qualifie de monarchie
présidentielle effectivement avec un
pouvoir gouvernant qui concentré dans la
conscience
ma question c'est vous vous considérez
qu'il faudrait supprimer ce 49-3 défin
parce que moi j'étais le 5 octobre dans
un très beau coloc à l'Académie
française sur faut-il réformer les
institutions et nous avions la chance
d'avoir les deux présidents Hollande et
Sarkozy qui venaient présenter leur
réforme conception des institutions
alors ce qui m'a beaucoup frappé pour
justement vous allez voir ça c'est la 6e
République Nicolas Sarkozy à quel
endroit la réforme de 2008
à Nicolas Sarkozy qui est l'auteur de sa
réforme constitutionnelle de 2008 il dit
exactement ce que dit vos collègues et
UPS c'est un aveu de faiblesse en disant
je n'ai jamais utilisé le 49-3 c'est un
aveu de faiblesse je trouve que c'est
quelque chose alors je suppose assez en
désaccord avec Nicolas Sarkozy parce que
il peut considérer que lui
personnellement il n'utilise pas ce 49-3
pour des raisons politiques mais de
vouloir considérer qu'on voit changer
les institutions définitivement sur ces
questions là parce que le contexte peut
changer je trouve que c'est une position
qui est me semble-t-il néfaste mais je
note simplement que vous êtes
effectivement assez proche de l'esprit
de la réforme moi ma question est très
simple souhaiteriez-vous
abolir tout simplement le 49-3 mais
évidemment de toute façon y compris dans
une situation de budget y compris dans
une situation de budget je vous invite à
lire le programme de la France insoumise
et ce qu'on se sur quoi on plaît depuis
des années et en plus moi j'ai écrit un
livre dessus qui s'appelle guide citoyen
de la Sixième République on change
totalement de pourquoi
je vous ramène quand même à notre sujet
j'ai un bouton ON j'ai pas de bouton off
je vais dire je suis interrissable j'ai
justement rapidement
je pense qu'il faut revenir à ce qui se
passe en situation exactement dans cette
situation pour moi le blocage il ne
vient pas du Parlement puisqu'on a eu
des votes majoritaires le blocage il est
à l'Élysée monsieur oui on a voté oui
pardon il fallait il faut suivre on a on
a on a on a voté un tas de fleurs pour
des mesures justement je reprends la
main s'il vous plaît Raquel Garrido
j'aimerais qu'on soit justement de quoi
on parle sur quel texte on débatte ce
soir et oui mais j'aimerais quand même
un argument qui est utilisé qui consiste
à dire que
les oppositions en toute hypothèse
n'auraient pas voté le budget parce que
c'est ça fondamentalement la
justification alors
les républicains je voudrais tous dit
sur ce point parce que c'est vrai que la
V1 du budget tout le monde était contre
tout le monde sauf les amis du Président
mais la V2 alors je sais qu'elle est
soumise au vote
merci de cette transition celle qui
intègre tous les amendements qui ont été
votés majoritairement on ne saura jamais
finalement parce que le gouvernement
n'ose pas je vous donne la parole
monsieur comme c'est c'est premier mais
d'abord justement de quoi parle-t-on de
quel budget de quel texte précisément
puisque la première ministre bonsoir
Stéphanie Despierre et merci d'être avec
nous en direct de la fête des quatre
colonnes Elisabeth borne a dit que c'est
un des états le décalque du projet de
loi de finances première partie initiale
mais que des amendements avaient été
repris y compris proposé par
l'opposition à quoi ressemble le texte
ce soir
et bien écoutez le texte ressemble dans
sa version finale le gouvernement a
repris une centaine d'amendements votés
par les députés mais seulement une
poignée venue de l'opposition il y a
donc la TVA à 5,5% sur les masques ça
c'était une idée à des socialistes un
coup de pouce fiscal pour les PME
c'était une proposition à des
républicains dans le texte aussi un
crédit d'impôt plus important pour les
gardes d'enfants la fin de l'avantage
fiscale sur les jets privés une
augmentation du soutien collectivité
locale ça c'était des demandes émanant
de la majorité tout cela devrait coûter
environ 700 millions d'euros au budget
de l'État en revanche il n'y a pas
d'amendement très symbolique ou qui
modifie en profondeur ce budget Bercy
c'est assez logique à maintenir ses
lignes rouges pas de taxes
exceptionnelles donc sur les super
profits dont on attend parler seulement
la contribution prévue par l'Union
européenne rien non plus sur les super
dividendes malgré la pression maintenu
jusqu'au bout par le modem pourtant
allié à d'Emmanuel Macron le
gouvernement a également dit non au
rétablissement de l'exit tax il a aussi
écarté le crédit d'IMP sur les résidents
des pads beaucoup trop coûteux pour les
finances publiques selon les macronistes
c'est merci beaucoup Stéphanie on vous
retrouve un petit peu plus tard c'est
vrai François Cornier boligeon autant
certains amendements poussés on pense
beaucoup à ces amendes symboliques sur
les supers profits par les oppositions
n'ont pas été repris on connaît le point
de vue du gouvernement mais sur ce de
vos alliés de modem sur des super
dividendes là on s'étonne comment le
parlementaire que vous êtes il y a 19
députés Renaissance qui ont voté ces
amendements acceptent que le
gouvernement ne les reprennent pas mais
d'abord ça montre que nous avons un
débat au sein de la majorité
parlementaire et donc l'idée normale
c'est la liberté de chaque député il y a
pas de mandat impératif monsieur le
professeur constitutionnaliste nous
confirmera il y a pas de mandat
impératif article 27 et donc nous
pouvons prendre un certain nombre
d'initiatives nous avons considéré que
tout en pouvant réfléchir à une taxe sur
les super profils nous avons considéré
que ce que présentait le président Matéi
ne fonctionnait pas parce que
cet sur les actionnaires français des
entreprises et donc au final ça ne
réglait absolument pas le problème nous
nous travaillons au niveau européen pour
représentation nationale c'est là où
peut-être les Français auraient du mal à
comprendre mais là c'est ce qui est
important de de dire c'est que on nous
avons examiné plusieurs milliers
d'amendements dans 99% des cas le vote
s'est fait de façon solide autour de la
majorité mais nous avons eu dans
quelques dizaines de cas une trentaine
une des alliances à la fois opportuniste
et une opportunes entre elle et fille le
PCF Europe Écologie Les Verts le PS LR
et le rassemblement national et donc au
fond c'est cette alliance de
circonstances
les alliances parfois de circonstances
enfin la démocratie c'est quand même là
en l'occurrence nous examinons un texte
sur le budget donc la France a besoin
d'un budget pour l'année 2023 est-ce que
nous oppositions dans leur grande
diversité ont un budget à alternatif à
proposer qui pourrait rassembler une
majorité de députés parce que c'est très
clair dans ce que dit ma collègue
Garrido elle a sa conception de la
démocratie la démocratie française ne
lui convient pas c'est la Constitution
la démocratie je crois qu'on est tous
d'accord pour dire que quand a lieu
c'est démocratique c'est-à-dire que
votre conception de la démocratie c'est
de couper la parole donc là vous avez
une conception la démocratie française
de se respecter de s'écouter moi je vous
ai écouté tout à l'heure sans vous
interrompre et donc vous avez la
démocratie française vous l'avez dit ne
vous convient pas
ce que j'ai dit j'ai
donc c'est pas la peine de me faire dire
ce que j'ai pas dit tant mieux pour les
gens c'est vous qui êtes en train de la
démocratie
mais vous avez une conception très
particulière de la démocratie
vous vous êtes peut-être content de
venir ici 1000 € par mois voter mais moi
ça me révulse mais alors donc c'est pas
la peine de me faire on va laisser
critique la 5e République franchement et
pas la démocratie vénéneuse
de le dire parce que en l'occurrence
mais
niveau justement
nous sommes en train de débattre et vous
êtes vous allez j'ai honte pour vous
Philippe de Rodier ce qu'on voit là
c'est quand même qu'à un moment donné
des groupes essaient de former une
majorité pour proposer des textes de loi
et en l'occurrence un budget est-ce
qu'il y a une majorité autour de la
France insoumise pour proposer un budget
alternatif la réponse est NON et donc à
partir du moment où nous avons pris le
temps des débats à partir du moment où
nous avons pris le temps de la
discussion le temps de la décision est
venu et donc le gouvernement engage le
49-3 parce que il est temps d'adopter ce
budget avec des mesures qui protègent
les Français qui font en sorte de ne pas
augmenter les impôts ni de creuser le
déficit public c'est ça je voudrais
donner la parole à nos experts parce que
on voit que voilà on est dans un face à
face et c'est que le début si j'ose dire
on attend un nouveau 49-3 sur le projet
de budget de la Sécurité sociale combien
de temps ça peut tenir est-ce qu'on est
dans la posture où est-ce qu'on va vers
l'immobilisme
non là il y a pas d'immobilisme
précisément puisque il faut bien
rappeler quand même à ceux qui n'ont pas
que c'est une cartouche on peut utiliser
dans le budget mais qu'une fois après
pour une session absolument ça c'est
vrai d'ailleurs c'est sans doute là une
erreur qui a été commise en 2008
peut-être qu'on y reviendra mais oui on
va probablement réutiliser le 49-3 sans
doute déjà sur la seconde partie de du
projet de loi de finance d'ailleurs été
annoncé par Gabriel Attal peut-être
également sur le projet de loi de
financement et la sécurité sociale puis
là on est au stade de la première
lecture il y aura d'autres lectures donc
le 49-3 effectivement va être pas mal
mobilisé au cours ne serait-ce que des
prochaines semaines d'ici au fait les
Français vont le comprendre les premiers
sondages avant le 49-3 montrent un élab
pour BFM TV que 66% d'entre eux sont
plutôt opposés à l'utilisation de cette
cet outil là je les comprends ou du
moins je comprends cette cette position
parce que le 49-3 est effectivement
associé à un déni de démocratie parce
que on donne l'impression qu'il coupe la
parole mais je la foi je vais dans votre
sens mais je n'y vais pas totalement
parce que ce n'est pas totalement vrai
tout dépend de quel instant est-ce qu'on
mobilise le 49 3 et je maintiens que je
pense que le mobiliser aujourd'hui sur
un projet de loi de finance dont la
discussion n'est pas achevée et
prématurée il faut effectivement à un
moment donné sécuriser le vote parce que
la France insoumise malgré tout le
respect que j'ai pour ce groupe
parlementaire n'est pas majoritaire non
plus
analyse je pense que moi vraiment je
suis très très inquiet sur le fait qu'on
défende que l'idée que le 49-3 c'est un
démocratie parce que voilà on a vu un
débat vif il se passe des choses à
l'Assemblée c'est une très bonne
nouvelle c'est un peu théâtral et
effectivement les rôles sont écrits à
l'avance mais c'est une très bonne
nouvelle que cela se passe qu'on soit
ici en train de débattre sur une journée
qui pas la journée des nups mais une
journée qui a été passionnante et qui
est intéressante et qui nous fait
prendre conscience des divisions il est
beaucoup bien préférable que ces
divisions s'expriment dans
ce beau lieu de l'Assemblée nationale
que à l'extérieur donc voilà je trouve
qu'il y a là quelque chose qui est
éminemment positif et de ce point de vue
là cet usage de ce 403 est une bonne
nouvelle pour la démocratie c'est pour
moi exactement le scénario inverse on a
quelque chose qui relève de du dynamisme
et de l'expression des oppositions et
des désaccords on sort du consensus plat
merci beaucoup un dernier petit mot puis
on va partir faire des quatre colonnes
premièrement une relève pas de la
responsabilité du Parlement de proposer
le budget de la France c'est un projet
de loi de finance pas une proposition ça
n'existe pas donc quand on dit aux
oppositions vous n'avez pas de budget
alternatif c'est faux du point de vue
institutionnel pardon la caisse ça n'est
pas la question qui est posée oui
d'abord vous n'en avez pas bien sûr
capable vous les renaissances d'accepter
de perdre un scrutin quand vous êtes
dans l'hémicycle est-ce que vous êtes
capable de respecter le scrutin quand
vous le perdez et la réponse elle est
clairement non et si vous aviez un peu
de courage et de principe démocratie
et j'ai bien compris mais dans quelles
circonstances est-ce qu'on peut perdre
un scrutin dans l'hémicycle nous perdons
oui et quand est-ce qu'on est
minoritaire
quand vous gagnez vous êtes minoritaire
ne pouvait gagner un vote que quand vous
vous alliez au rassemblement national
mais on ne constate si vous voulez
merci à vous je vais vous laisser
débattre en dehors de ce studio je vous
le dis allez
tout simplement national s'il vous plaît
s'il vous plaît
où se trouve que ce soir les voies du
rassemblement national et de la nupaise
ne se mélangent pas puisque chacun
dépose sa motion de censure de chacun de
son côté merci beaucoup je vous garde
avec vous Jean-Philippe de rosier je
vous remercie infiniment d'être venu sur
le plateau de LCP on va tout de suite
partir celle des quatre colonnes avec
Stéphanie Despierres qui est avec
Laurent marquantelli le patron du groupe
horizon à l'Assemblée alliée des
macronistes
Elisabeth borne a déclenché le 49-3 tout
en expliquant qu'elle avait dialogué le
calendrier budgétaire est serré mais
est-ce qu'on aurait pas pu laisser un
peu plus de temps au débat ici à
l'Assemblée nous avons d'une certaine
manière épuisée le temps programmé de la
première partie du PLF du projet de loi
de finance je pense qu'on a eu le temps
de débattre au cours de la semaine qui
vient de s'écouler un débat de qualité
moi je trouve assez déplacé de dire que
on n'a pas laissé le temps au débat et
que ce débat n'a pas été de bonne
qualité et aujourd'hui nous prenons nos
responsabilités et nous engageons à
cette procédure qui est prévue par la
Constitution vous êtes président du
groupe horizon allié de d'Emmanuel
Macron vous aviez proposé des
amendements là il y en a un qui est
repris pour renforcer un peu le soutien
aux collectivités locales est-ce que
vous en êtes satisfait ou est-ce que
vous êtes déçu de la version finale du
texte je suis pas déçu je ne voterai pas
la censure pas aujourd'hui à faire durer
un suspense qui n'existe pas je suis
particulièrement satisfait que
commandement soit retenu pour une bonne
simple raison c'est que nous voyons bien
que la situation des prix de l'énergie
pèse sur les ménages pèse sur les
entreprises mais elle pèse également sur
les collectivités territoriales et dans
notre groupe nous avons une forte
attache à la défense des intérêts des
collectivités locales qui contribuent
grandement à la vie de notre pays c'est
la raison pour laquelle aujourd'hui je
suis particulièrement satisfait que cet
amendement soit retenu merci beaucoup
d'avoir été à nos côtés Merci à VOUS
Stéphanie Despierres et nous ont rejoint
sur ce plateau Philippe Vigier bonsoir
merci d'être là député MoDem
d'Eure-et-Loir le modem est-il
véritablement heureux ce soir puisque
son amendement sur les supersdibles ne
fait pas partie du 49.3 retenu vous nous
le direz bonsoir Philippe Gosselin
bonsoir et merci d'être là député les
républicains de la Manche enfin
bienvenue à vous Philippe Balard députés
du rassemblement national député de
l'Oise Jean-Philippe de Rozier
constitutionnaliste est resté à mes
côtés parce qu'on a besoin d'experts
dans ce débat on le sent musclé est très
politique premier tour de table on
disait que le 49-3 c'est jamais
forcément une partie de plaisir pour un
député même quand on est dans la
majorité sur quand on est député MoDem
d'autant plus non est-ce que vous
regrettez que cette amendement sur des
super dividendes adoptées avec 19
députés Renaissance ne soient pas dans
le texte soit sur un regret lorsqu'on
abonnement qu'on a porté avec courage un
moment juste pour taxer c'est super
dividendes il n'est pas été retenu bon
écoutez c'est c'est la loi du 49-3 c'est
le gouvernement qui retient
naturellement dans sa version finale les
amendements qu'il a voulu porter mais je
vais vous dire on s'arrêtera pas là de
toute façon continuera ce débat et que
c'est installé dans l'opinion publique
c'est
redéposé en deuxième lecture
parce que la France de 2022 n'est pas
assez de 2017 et qui ont été obligés de
faire passer un signal au moment où on
sait qu'il y a eu des distributions
dividendes de très importantes en plus
pardonnez-moi je pense que la fiscalité
que vous rajoutez c'était très simple la
fameuse flat taxe être à à 35 c'est pas
énormément révolutionnaire mais c'est un
amendement symbole et nous sommes
attachés à une certaine justice sociale
donc nous continuerons on a tout entendu
de côté des oppositions aujourd'hui les
mots étaient très forts coup de force
simulacre de démocratie vous faites
bande à part à côté émotion de censure
ça n'était pas forcément la position
initiale du rassemblement national vous
êtes à ce point dans cette dans cette
radicalité là de d'opposition vous êtes
un peu plus en retrait ce soir je pense
qu'on peut pas parler de radicalité
franchement ferme constructif et puis
oui quand on a des choses à dire on lit
l'amendement du MoDem parce que il y a
le résultat du vote quand même qui est
intéressant de mémoire c'était 277 voix
pour et 88 contre c'est à dire qu'il y a
quand même là c'était pas une alliance
de circonstances il y avait quand même
de très très très très nombreux députés
qui soutenaient cet amendement et puis
bon on a compris que il était mis à la
poubelle
le gouvernement vous diriez ce 49-3
quand on a recours aux 49-3 oui alors
d'habitude il était plutôt utilisé pour
si on remonte un petit peu l'histoire on
se souviendrait mon bar qui l'utilisait
souvent parce que le RPR veut des pôles
budget alors qu'il était dans la
majorité c'était plutôt à l'intérieur de
la majorité quand il y avait des
problèmes qu'on utilisait le 49-3 là
c'est un cas de figure plutôt plutôt
dans ces cas-là vous allez pas
franchement jusqu'à vouloir renverser le
gouvernement parce que il faut bien
expliquer quand même à ce qui nous
regardent avec deux motions de censure
aucune va de chance d'être adopté on est
dans un débat de posture on va avoir un
débat de censure et on connaît la fin du
film pourquoi mais quand on vote une
censure faut quand même expliquer vous
me corrigez si c'est une erreur mais on
rentre pas dans l'hémicycle en disant ah
moi le gouvernement il vote pas je lève
le bras je veux être la censure il y a
un texte qui fait 2 3 pages avec les
choses décrites alors si la nuit pêche
connait pas le texte de la UPS mais nous
dit nous
[Musique]
est déjà tombé de toute façon je le dis
en souriant mais il n'a jamais été
question évidemment que les républicains
viennent ajouter du chaos au chaos et
vote l'une ou l'autre des deux motions
qui sont totalement incompatibles du
reste entre elles vous venez de le
souligner non nous on dénonce non pas un
coup de force en tant que tel mais un
constat sinon d'échec en tout cas un
aveu de faiblesse un aveu de faiblesse
d'un gouvernement qui a une majorité
relative et qui doit se débrouiller avec
les ficelles de la 5e République le
Gouvernement qui dans ce texte a quand
même fait des gestes en direction des
républicains vous le reconnaissez la
fameuse CVAE la contribution sur la
valeur ajoutée des entreprises a été
supprimées ça n'a pas suffi on a
quelques éléments moi je vais vous citer
effectivement une imposition plus faible
pour les PME c'est très bien on conforte
parce qu'on s'est bagarré parce qu'on
s'est bagarré le budget de nos
collectivités locales qui en ont grand
besoin les comprenez que ceux qui nous
regardent il sait bien c'est bien et il
va falloir il vote pas on peut vous
savez un budget ce sont en réalité des
milliers de points différents quelques
grandes missions plus d'une vingtaine de
grandes missions c'est pas parce qu'on
attrape ici ou là quelques miettes que
pour autant la table est garnie donc oui
il y a quelques éléments qui sont
intéressants et on vient d'engranger
comme on avait pu avoir quelques
amendements voté sur le pouvoir d'achat
et on s'en était réjouis mais c'est un
budget qui ne correspond pas au projet
politique que nous souhaiterions pour la
France mais pour autant moi je ne vote
pas et les LR ne votent pas l'émotion de
censure parce qu'on va pas ajouter il
faut quand même le préciser il faut voir
l'état d'esprit en quelques mots de nos
concitoyens on a eu des manifs dimanche
on a eu des gravières les gens font la
queue à peu près partout pour trouver du
carburant on sait pas de quel bois au
sens propre comme au sens figuré on va
chauffer l'hiver prochain même si c'est
l'été indien en ce moment donc on va pas
ajouter du chaos
pivot des républicains se veut
responsables ce soir je vous redonne la
parole Philippe Vigier dans un instant
mais direction la salle des quatre
colonnes Stéphanie Despierre pour un
nouveau député nouvelle sensibilité
députée communiste monsieur
vous avez fait railler des jours durant
contre ce budget du gouvernement est-ce
que ce soir vous êtes déçu je suis pas
déçu la question c'est pas de la
déception c'est de savoir que en
imposant 49-3 le gouvernement rassassis
c'est-à-dire que il voulait dire qu'il
voulait qu'on construire un budget voilà
non seulement il n'a pas reconstruit
mais en plus il piétine tous les
amendements qu'on avait voté
majoritairement dans l'hémicycle donc
voilà il y a pas de déception il y a
juste une inquiétude pour la France il y
a eu 10 jours de débats il y a un
calendrier constitutionnel qui est
contraint il y a des dates fixes pour
lesquelles le budget doit être de la
France doit être adopté est-ce que le
gouvernement avait un autre choix
qu'est-ce qu'il serait ce serait passé
si le budget n'avait pas été adopté
avant début décembre si tout avait
traîné
la date limite c'est 31 décembre à
minuit c'est comme ça donc il y avait
encore beaucoup de temps on aurait pu
aussi enlever certaines lois qui sont
prévues après je pense à la Lovie ou à
d'autres lois de ce type pour avoir un
budget donc rien n'empêcher le
gouvernement et la présidente de
l'Assemblée nationale de proposer de
nouvelles usage de discussion c'est
d'ailleurs ce que j'ai demandé plusieurs
fois
durant plusieurs jours pour espérer que
qu'on aille au bout des amendements
merci beaucoup Merci à VOUS Stéphanie
des projets
ont bien compris ce qui va se jouer la
séquence qui vient en gros tout est figé
et ce budget en tout cas pour la
première partie va être adopté sur la
législature comment ça peut se passer
vous avez qu'une seule cartouche de 49.3
n'est pas complètement figé le film
Goslin l'habitude il est parlementaire
depuis quelques années comme je le suis
comme vous l'êtes oui chers collègues
mais saisons multiples mais mais je veux
dire quelque chose c'est que est-ce que
dans les budgets précédents on est
souvent allé chercher des amendements de
l'opposition certainement pas le fameux
320 millions d'euros qu'on met pas les
collectivités parce qu'on a été assez
nombreux à se retrouver là-dessus sur la
transmission des entreprises agricoles
je l'ai cité d'ailleurs comme ça
de commission de finances donc j'ai un
peu quand même une précision sur les
choses par exemple sur la transition des
PME le pendant sur la fiscalité des PME
de relever le seuil c'est quelque chose
qui est quand même enrichi
insuffisamment je peux comprendre dans
certaines oppositions mais en tout cas
c'est un texte qui a été le début d'une
co-construction alors expliquez-nous
parce qu'on n'a pas bien compris comment
ça va se passer alors comment ça va se
passer parce que là on est hors budget
que sur les prochains textes si on prend
des exemples concrets l'énergie
renouvelable c'est important le
nucléaire c'est fondamental comment vous
allez faire des gens on va faire vous
savez on apprend en marchant c'est en
fait il y a eu ce texte sur le pouvoir
d'achat on a pu constater qu'une
majorité c'était dégagée sur la réforme
d'assurance chômage qu'on a voté la
semaine dernière il a été largement voté
parce que d'ailleurs beaucoup impliqué
sur ce texte là on a pris en compte la
somme du proposition qui venait façon le
gouvernement moi j'ai lu quasiment de le
dire lorsque j'avais répondu à la prise
en panneaux à l'Assemblée à la tribune
de l'Assemblée le gouvernement doit
entendre sa tombe de choses et justement
vous pas énergies renouvelable mais on
peut parler des tests qui vont arriver
par exemple sur la réforme de retraite
il faudrait bien il faudra bien
mais pas obligatoirement chacun sera au
pied du mur on comparera les
républicains je crois que sur les
retraites on dit à cet homme de choses
le rassemblement national lorsque Marine
Le Pen a expliqué dans sa campagne
présidentielle que peut avoir une
retraite à taux plein il faudrait avoir
cotisé 42 ans je lui poserai une
question simple il a pas déjà fini
Balard quand vous commencez à 23 ans et
que vous travaillez 42 ans avoir une
retraite à taux plein ça fait 65 c'est
pas la retraite à 65 ans donc il va
falloir qu'on prenne qu'on écoute il y
aura les partenaires sociaux chacun
devra faire sa part et au final la
Constitution est bien faite quelqu'un
qui est expert et ce matière pour nous
le dire ça nous permet de naturellement
d'activer ce 49 ans et moi je souhaite
pas qu'on l'active du second possible je
souhaite on sait que pour les éléments
on sait qu'il faut le budget 6 49 3 sur
le sur le pontet
du 49-3 il faut le rappeler hors budget
comment vous voyez la suite est-ce qu'au
fond s'il y a pas s'il y a deux motion
ce soir une du RN une de les filles
c'est que vous avez pas du tout envie de
retourner aux urnes en cas de
dissolution
lors d'un Dinant dîner avait dit je
pense pour le modèle
jeudi sous et nous on est des chiches
nous je pense qu'on est le seul parti
et les législatives pourquoi vous vous
mêlez pas
et encore ça serait limite à condition
qu'il y a pas de de détection donc
moi je je crois encore une fois que on
doit travailler en responsabilité on a
des oppositions des projets pardon
politique qui sont clairement assumés et
qui font qu'on peut allier ou pas des
votes protestataires quand on a
effectivement et vous le dites bien des
objectifs en commun notre objectif n'est
pas aujourd'hui c'est très clair de nous
allier à la nupesse à la France
insoumise je reprends ce que disait
d'ailleurs Philippe Vigier ce que vous
disiez sur ce point j'ai pas de
difficulté à me trouver en accord avec
un collègue comme vous non nous on ne
critique pas la police on ne considère
pas que c'est le mal on veut un budget
de défense digne de ce nom on considère
pas qu'il y a une aliénation des
travailleurs inéluctables au sens
marxiste du terme on pas envie de
renverser la table voilà on éteint
gouvernement c'est très clair et en même
temps il y a aussi des voies divergences
au sein des républicains on a
l'impression que chacun dit un petit peu
ce qu'il a envie
de Roger vous êtes aussi un observateur
de la vie politique il y a trois congrès
qui arrive dans les groupes d'opposition
chez les républicains chez les
écologistes chez les socialistes en gros
jusqu'en janvier ces opposants là ont
intérêt à être les premiers opposants ça
veut dire que jusqu'en janvier tout est
figé c'est ça et qu'on pourra peut-être
imaginer des constructions de compromis
après alors les premiers opposants pas
forcément mais en tout cas marquer leur
opposition et pour le coup il y a une
contradiction donc parce que les
républicains effectivement on leur
congrès et ne marque pas leur opposition
ils ont dit que ils ne voteraient pas le
budget alors on peut interpréter ça de
façon ne pas voter le budget ça veut
dire soit s'abstenir soit voter contre
et là on peut effectivement c'est pour
ça que je dis encore une fois que le 49
trop tôt parce que si on était allé
jusqu'au bout peut-être qu'il y avait
des lignes qui auraient pu bouger mais
ce qui est certain en effet on dit
toujours c'est un usage on est dans
l'opposition on vote contre le budget on
est dans la majorité on vote pour une
sorte de loi des reins en politique
c'est sûr que le vent c'est sûr que le
vote sur la loi de finance détermine le
soutien ou l'opposition au gouvernement
les républicains ne peuvent pas se
permettre de rentrer dans la majorité
après ça c'est à eux de le décider moi
je regarde en tant que expert de la vie
publique et de la vie politique je vois
qu'il peut y avoir des constructions qui
peuvent être faites et des alliances si
le gouvernement fait des gestes vers les
républicains ça va être difficile pour
eux de systématiquement s'opposer
d'ailleurs je pense que cette sortie sur
concerne le PLFSS sur l'allongement de
l'âge légal de départ à la retraite
était soit une main tendue soit un piège
au vis-à-vis des républicains donc
est-ce que je réponds à votre question
est-ce que tout est un joli piège c'est
un une pièce bien sûr mais mais c'était
une naïveté et est-ce que tout est figé
de globalement sur les lois de finances
et de financement la sécurité sociale
les forces sont assez marquées donc oui
on va aller vers un recours au 49-3 ce
qui est très utile là où on a fait une
erreur en 2008 je termine là-dessus
après promis je me tais là où on a fait
une erreur en 2008 c'est que on a limité
le nombre de recours au 49-3 là on
aurait du limiter l’instant au président
Nicolas Sarkozy si on avait dit on ne
peut activer le 49-3 qu'à la fin du
débat législatif pour sécuriser le vote
et bien là la donne aurait été
différente
Philippe Gosselin et vous conclurez
Philippe Vigier mais d'abord Stéphanie
Despierres justement dernier 49-3 enfin
de la semaine je précise puisque après
celui-ci il pourrait y en avoir un autre
sur le budget de la Sécurité sociale
d'ici jeudi ou vendredi c'est bien ça
oui Myriam on attend déjà le deuxième
49-3 celui sur le budget de la Sécurité
sociale les députés commencent l'examen
du texte demain et là encore le
gouvernement ne devrait pas avoir à deux
majorités le Conseil des ministres a
donc donné son feu vert ce matin ce
deuxième 49-3 pour être intervenir vite
peut-être dès demain soir ou vendredi ça
devrait être aussi rapide pour des
raisons politiques hier encore une
partie des députés Renaissance ont
demandé à Elisabeth borne de déclencher
le 49-3 plus vite que sur le budget
global de la France ces derniers jours
ils ont eu l'impression de passer du
temps
inutilement à l'Assemblée alors qu'il
savait dès le départ que tout se
jouerait par 49-3 et ce n'est pas fini
même s'il y a un deuxième 49.3 d'ici la
fin de la semaine après le sur le budget
de la Sécurité sociale le gouvernement
devrait l'utiliser à nouveau les députés
doivent valider la partie dépenses du
budget global du pays ça ce sera en
novembre à défaut la le gouvernement
Recoura à nouveau à ce 49,3 et il y a
des contraintes de calendrier l'exécutif
pas le choix pour se conformer à la
constitution la totalité de ses lois
budgets Jetair doit être adopté avant la
fin de l'année c'est à VOUS Stéphanie
Despierre il nous reste 30 secondes pour
conclure ce débat passionné passionnant
Philippe Gosselin puis Philippe Vigier
rapidement oui bah écoutez nous encore
une fois on fait preuve de
responsabilité on ne s'accordera pas sur
le budget pas plus sur le PNSS
d'ailleurs on voit bien hein 49 alinéa 3
peut en cacher un autre c'est comme les
trains mais il est pas impossible qu'on
se retrouve sur un certain nombre de
sujets on va pas non plus à chaque fois
refuser ce qui pourra aller dans le bon
sens par exemple à la loi d'orientation
du ministère de l'Intérieur plus de
policiers
de l'immigration et de la police pour
conclure le mot de la fin pour conclure
une première partie de budget je salue
l'état des responsabilités
s'il vous plaît
c'est à dire que le résultat est clair
deuxièmement la construction et la
co-construction ça doit être le travail
pour 2023 merci beaucoup merci d'avoir
participé tous les quatre
de votre dernier livre la responsabilité
des gouvernants qui s'affiche à l'écran
c'est aux éditions Lexis merci à vous
quatre on ne se quitte pas sans les
parties prit de nos affranchies du
mercredi ce soir Isabelle Lasserre du
Figaro pour l'actu internet
Isabelle qui va revenir ce soir sur le
retour à Téhéran de la grimpeuse
iranienne elnaz récabi depuis son geste
tout sauf anodin d'escalader sans son
voile et puis Fanny guinochet de France
Info pour l'économie qui va nous parler
de la course à la voiture électrique sur
toutes les lèvres au salon de l'auto et
puis une nouvelle histoire d'école enfin
avec Yanis Robert ce soir il va dire
merci à tous les profs d'histoire-géo du
pays vous verrez nos affranchis les
voici bonsoir à tous les trois on
commence par l'International tiens une
une femme à l'honneur qui est de retour
après quelques jours de disparition on
parle ce soir avec vous Isabelle
championne d'escalade iranienne qui
avait osé concourir sans son voile sans
son hijab au championnat d'Asie à Séoul
et depuis lundi ses amis n'avaient plus
de nouvelles elle est réapparue à
Téhéran oui il avait plus de il n'avait
plus de nouvelles et elle avait on s'en
souvient regarder sur ces images défier
à distance le régime des mots là vous
voyez son élégance et ça détermination
elle a troqué le voile islamique
obligatoire pour les sportifs iraniennes
même à l'étranger contre un bandeau noir
à la mode autour de la tête alors bien
évidemment ce geste de liberté a été
interprété comme un soutien mouvement de
contestation qui secoue l'Iran depuis la
disparition il y a un mois de Macha
Amini vous vous souvenez Myriam cette
jeune femme qui a été arrêtée et frappée
à mort parce qu'elle avait justement mis
son voile de manière incorrecte selon la
police des morts depuis de folles
rumeurs couraient sur Internet et le
nazekabi dans le passeport et le
téléphone ont apparemment été confisqué
aurait été pas été puis emprisonné et on
l'a vu réapparaître très tôt ce matin à
l'aéroport de Téhéran où elle a été
acclamée par la foule sauf qu'elle n'a
pas l'air aussi souriante qu'elle ne
l'était assez haute au contraire elle a
le visage inquiet est fermé on l'a vu
sur ses images que vous venez de voir et
vous avez peut-être remarqué les les
molosses qui les qui l'entouraient
peut-être des passes d'aranes ces
gardiens de la révolution en tout cas ce
sont des hommes du régime et ce sont
sans douteuses qui lui ont inspiré ce
qui ressemble Myriam à une confession
forcée à la télévision elle naze
récabilla du s'excuser dire que son
voile était tombé par inadvertance et
qu'en aucun cas en aucun cas il ne
s'agissait d'un acte intentionnel oui
évidemment la répression depuis le début
de ce mouvement lancé par les familles
raniennes cette répression ne faiblit
pas les mêmes préférences elle a déjà
fait plus de 200 morts et elle ne semble
pas faiblir la grimpeuse iranienne qui a
toujours son mari à Téhéran qui veut
absolument éviter de se retrouver
derrière les barreaux et bien ces
excuses en public lui ont sans doute
permis départ sans doute épargner un
séjour dans l'épouvantable prison des
vignes en tout cas ça c'est dans
l'immédiat mais elle ne fasseront pas le
symbole qu'elle est devenu en grimpant
comme ça tête nue sur son mur d'escalade
la révolution tient une nouvelle héroïne
de plus c'est juste dire merci beaucoup
merci Isabelle Fanny tout le monde ne
parlait que de ça au Salon de l'Auto la
voiture électrique tous les
constructeurs doivent s'y mettre et très
vite ces Brussel qu'il commande sauf
qu'il y a un risque c'est d'offrir un
boulevard aux Chinois effectivement
parce que la voiture thermique celle
d'avant c'est la c'est ce que ça fait
les Européens et les Français notamment
on est très fort alors que les moteurs
électriques bien les Chinois eux ont
pris un peu d'avance parce que vous
l'avez dit Bruxelles à partir 2035
interdit toutes les ventes de voitures
neuves qui seront thermiques 2035 c'est
demain donc les constructeurs s'y
mettent mais c'est quasiment un cadeau
que l'on fait à la Chine parce que la
Chine a des avantages concurrentiels en
la matière d'abord les lithiums le
cobalt qu'on fait venir de Chine pour
faire les batteries tout ça vient d'Asie
et puis il y a aussi les composants
électroniques qui viennent aussi d'Asie
on est extrêmement dépendant alors
certes la voiture électrique vous me
direz pour le climat c'est évidemment
louable mais c'est un tapis rouge que
l'on déroule au chinois on est dépendant
aussi des Chinois en plus de cela les
Chinois ont déjà pris de l'avance
effectivement les Chinois il faut savoir
déjà que c'est le premier les premiers
constructeurs au monde de voiture devant
les Américains devant les Européens
alors c'est dire s'ils savent faire et
c'est vrai que le premier constructeur
aujourd'hui qui vend des voitures
électriques c'est un CHINOIS même devant
Tesla c'est biwy alors même si les
ventes de voitures électriques
progressent en France et bien une grande
partie de ces de ces voitures elles
viennent elles sont importées et elles
viennent notamment d'Asie et ce n'est
que du début de la déferlante parce que
les Chinois veulent inonder le marché
européen avec des petites voitures
designées citadines et puis beaucoup
moins cher parce qu'un des freins dans
l'achat d'une voiture électrique
aujourd'hui ça reste le prix c'est 40
fois c'est 40% plus cher qu'une voiture
thermique et les chinois ils sont
d'ailleurs très très nombreux ils sont
venus en masse au Salon de l'Auto si
vous allez dans les travées vous verrez
les stands parce qu'ils veulent inonder
ce marché alors il y a des marques que
l'on ne connaît pas mais dont on va
entendre parler je vous parlais tout à
l'heure de bewidy mais il y aura aussi
mg aura ou encore CRS on a une chance de
résister comment réagir face à cette
offensive de Pékin sur la voiture
électrique déjà se réveiller arrêtez
d'être naïf se dire qu'il faut mettre
quand même quelques protections à
l'entrée de l'Europe alors Bruno Le
Maire mise de l'économie essaye de
porter le sujet mais ça n'est pas facile
arrêtez aussi de sponsoriser des voiture
électrique que l'on importe 80% d'entre
elles je vous le disais sont importés en
ciblant les aides sur des productions
françaises voire européenne et puis
c'est aussi l'objectif qui a pris la
France essayer de produire nos propres
voitures électriques c'est ce que
font-ils ces Renault mais ça n'est pas
sûr étant donné l'offensive comme vous
le disiez ce soit suffisant merci Fanny
déjà
personne vélo électrique vélo tout court
je crois c'est bien ce soir je rappelle
d'ailleurs que vous êtes professeur
d'histoire-géographie à Saint-Denis vous
vouliez revenir sur la cérémonie qui
s'est tenue à la Sorbonne samedi dernier
deux ans après l'assassinat de Samuel
Paty pour la première fois le prix
Samuel Paty a été remis par
l'association des professeurs
d'histoire-géographie oui Myriam le
thème est de cette jeu après-midi était
sommes-nous toujours libre de nous
exprimer trois classes guidées par leur
professeur ont été l'oréade parmi ces
classes celle de Jean-Emmanuel Dumoulin
on l'écoute ce qui m'a mis la puce à
l'oreille c'est un instant en cours un
instant justement autour du débat si on
pouvait ou pas en France critiquer une
religion et là il y a eu un instant un
peu magique je dirais aujourd'hui où une
élève m'a dit désolé mais on va pas
parler de ça parce qu'on va se battre et
à ce moment là moi ça fait tilt et je me
suis dit non on va apprendre à débattre
moi je ne connais pas Jean-Emmanuel
Dumoulin je sais juste qu'il est
professeur d'histoire dans le
Puy-de-Dôme et que sa classe a été
primée pour un podcast sur la liberté
d'expression justement en présence de la
famille de Samuel Paty et du ministre
monsieur papendiere
donc vous voulez nous parler ce soir non
Myriam je voudrais revenir aux propos
que nous venons d'entendre ils sont le
reflet en fait de l'engagement de tous
ses preuves qui œuvrent au quotidien
pour que les enfants devenus des élèves
deviennent des citoyens ces mots m'ont
rappelés la parole de Ferdinand Buisson
vous savez ce grand pédagogue monsieur
homme politique français qui disait que
le rôle de la République c'est de faire
des républicains c'est la mission que
remplissent sans cesse les enseignants
comme Monsieur Dumoulin les enseignants
qui croient dans leur mission c'est ça
il faut pas enjoliver non plus trop les
choses nous savons qu'il y a beaucoup
d'affaires en matière de formation et
notamment sur le sens même de l'école de
la République notamment chez les chez
les plus jeunes profs mais il faut aussi
savoir que d'autres ont une conscience
aiguë de leur mission à l'image de
Monsieur Dumoulin et de ses collègues
qui ont été primés avec lui convaincus
de la nécessité républicaine ils
embarquent d'ailleurs les élèves dans
des projets des projets ambitieux pour
lesquels il ne compte ni leurs heures ni
leur peine quand bien même nous savons
qu'ils sont mal payés parfois mal
considérés et pourtant ils sont
indispensables au combien est
indispensable d'abord pour encourager
leurs élèves dans leur progression
scolaire mais également pour les ouvrir
au monde parce que l'école ce n'est pas
seulement le lieu de la construction de
son avenir professionnel et personnel
elle offre aussi la formidable
possibilité de l'émancipation citoyenne
c'est ce que font ces professeurs c'est
ce que faisait aussi Samuel Paty avait
conviction et avec l'engagement qui
caractérise ce type d'enseignants ça
veut dire quoi on leur dit pas assez
merci à nos professeurs il faudrait les
remercier plus souvent au-delà des
augmentations de salaire et de la
revalorisation oui je le crois je crois
sincèrement je voudrais vous lire Myriam
si vous me permettez ce qui a écrit une
ancienne des élèves de Samuel Paty après
son assassinat par un islamiste de 18
ans elle a été cité samedi en Sorbonne
par la Mickaël la sœur de Monsieur Paty
voici ce que dit cette jeune fille merci
pour le travail que vous avez fait vous
m'avez enseigné l'histoire géographique
comme personne ne l'avait fait merci
d'avoir été mon professeur pendant deux
ans merci d'avoir été une certaine
manière d'une certaine manière dans ma
vie on se voyait du lundi au vendredi
quand même merci pour ces blagues à la
fin des cours certes qui n'était pas
vraiment drôle mais du moins il essayait
le professeur de faire en sorte que si
on allait mal ça pouvait nous remonter
le moral merci Monsieur Merci pour tout
alors nous aussi je crois que nous
devons dire merci à tous ces enseignants
merci à vous à l'enseignant que vous
êtes et merci pour cette pour cette
chronique ça fait du bien merci Yanis
Robert vous souvenez d'un prof
d'histoire géo qui a changé les choses
pour vous évidemment
en terminale je m'en souviens très très
bien et il était vraiment exceptionnel
c'était alors on parlait pas encore des
caricatures mais sur l'ouverture sur le
monde et notamment sur la façon
d'aborder les sujets la tolérance oui
évidemment participé je crois qu'on a
tous un enseignant en nous d'école de la
République qui est là qui et je renvoie
d'ailleurs au très beau discours au très
beau texte de Michael Patty qui a pris
la parole pour la première fois la sœur
de Samuel pati à la Sorbonne vous
pourrez évidemment le trouver en ligne
merci les affranchis et à très vite pour
voir ou revoir cette émission
rendez-vous sur la chaîne Youtube de LCP
bien sûr très belle soirée documentaire
Jean-Pierre Gratien tout de suite à
demain
[Musique]